marine le pen la présidente du front
national est l'invité de preuves par 3
public sénat afp dailymotion bonsoir et
merci d'être avec nous et avec guillaume
daudin de l' agence france-presse
et puis perrine tarneaud de public sénat
tout à l'heure la situation économique
et sociale servent aux ambitions
électorales marine le pen pour les
prochains scrutins l'élection municipale
d'abord ou d'ailleurs pour la première
fois on vous donne gagnants et gagnantes
puisque vous êtes sur la liste à hénin
beaumont
et puis également le scrutin européen
bien sûr qui permet on le sait à chaque
fois aux électeurs d'envoyer un message
de colère
si un tiers des français disent
aujourd'hui adhérer à vos idées selon le
dernier baromètre tns sofres on constate
quand même qu'une large majorité reste
style à certaines de vos propositions
phares comme par exemple la sortie de
l'euro mais nous en parlerons tout à
l'heure françois hollande s'investit on
le voit à fond aujourd'hui dans son
nouveau positionnement que vous allez
pouvoir juger positionnement pro
entreprise pro capitaux propres
investisseurs étrangers le jour même où
peugeot citroën ouvre son capital aux
chinois dongfeng est ce que vous êtes
inquiet de cela et rassuré par ailleurs
de la décision de l'état français
d'entrer à la même hauteur dans le
capital 14% ont de toute façon que
jamais se réjouir quand une industrie
française est obligé de faire appel à
des capitaux étrangers
ça veut dire que cette entreprise va mal
cette industrie va mal et nous le savons
et elle va mal parce que l'euro est trop
fort et que donc elle n'arrive plus à
être compétitives à cause du taux de
change est fait rationnelle à la faute
de la famille peugeot des erreurs de
stratégie non jaune est objectivement je
ne le pense pas je pense que si l'euro
était moins chère l'industrie française
s'en sortir est beaucoup mieux et donc
l'industrie automobile aussi alors qu'il
entrait dans le capital de
des chinois est une chose si ça reste à
14% bon on peut éventuellement
considérer que c'est supportable moi
combien ça serait un support dès que dès
que le poids est plus trop important et
que par conséquent je peux pas vous dire
parce que ça dépend de combien détenus
le capital est détenu et par qui voilà
il peut y avoir des accords dans une
entreprise avec des dt temps des
détenteurs de capitaux qui se mettent
ensemble pour pouvoir défendre une
politique est contraire à celle de
l'intérêt de la france bon mois le
danger pourquoi je suis inquiète parce
que je sais très bien que les chinois à
différence des français d'ailleurs
le gouvernement chinois ne pense qu'à
son intérêt et cas l'intérêt de son
industrie à lui or il est en train de
développer une politique industrielle en
matière automobile de développement de
marques chinoises et donc je peux
éventuellement m'inquiéter que cette
décision n'entraîne pas un transfert
délocalisations des centres de décision
et d'innovation vers la chine
parce que évidemment là on y perdrait de
notre substance et et on serait appauvri
inquiète et en même temps rassuré je
vous le disais par la décision du
gouvernement d'entrer dans le capital et
on entend arnaud montebourg qui utilise
le mot patriotisme ça peut vous plaire à
ceux du patriotisme
oh mais c'est bien sûr que ça peut me
plaire tout à fait ça peut me plaire il
ya 15 ou sous win mais je soutiens la
démarche pense que la démarche pense que
l'état doit prendre ses responsabilités
pour une grande entreprise française
telle que celle là qui est une grande
entreprise dans un secteur hautement
stratégique et surtout gros pourvoyeur
d'emplois le seul problème si vous
voulez c'est que le patriotisme il pleut
il s'arrête là pour une raison simple
c'est qu'on ne peut pas mettre en oeuvre
une priorité nationale
c'est à dire qu'on ne peut pas mettre en
oeuvre à une crise il est vrai pas les a
sauvé l'entreprise met d'accord mais par
exemple un conseil régional qui veut
totalement changé son parc de voitures
eh bien il n'a pas la possibilité
d'acheter les voitures françaises il
n'en a pas le droit parce que l'union
européenne interdit elle est là la
limite à la politique de monsieur
montebourg de la même manière quand
nicolas sarkozy à son époque avait fait
le même cinéma que monsieur montebourg
et avait expliqué que l'état allait
venir en aide aux sous-traitants
automobiles français eh bien ils avaient
juste omis de dire que l'union
européenne s'y opposerait
opposés et par conséquent on n'a pas pu
venir en aide à ce secteur qui est un
secteur essentiel alors françois
hollande le patriote un puisqu'il se
présente aussi comme ça on l'a entendu
lors de sa conférence de presse a
critiqué en vantant où vous l'avez vu
l'attractivité française une conception
étriquée de notre intérêt national ceux
qui ont peur de s'ouvrir au monde at il
dit ce qu'il veut
ceux qui veulent se protéger c'est vous
oui et parle que de moi de façon à
chaque fois cette conférence de presse
il ya un petit un petit pique contre une
petite pique contre le front national
c'est l'homme qui murmurait à l'oreille
des pigeons maintenant françois hollande
les choses sont claires je veux dire il
a pris la décision d'aller déroulé le
tapis rouge devant les grandes
multinationales et si possible les
grandes multinationales étrangères
c'est son choix ça n'est pas de ne pas
figurer ces investissements qui viennent
de l'extérieur créés dans des emplois
oui très bien nourris crée pas d'emplois
c'est de créer dé l'emploi ce sont les
tpe les pme et les pmi dans l'assolement
et ce sont celles là qui sont flinguer
consciencieusement alors je vais vous
donner par exemple deux éléments dont
personne n'a parlé ils ont pris une
décision monsieur ayrault en
l'occurrence pour requalifier les
apprentis en salariés vous savez quelles
conséquences ça va avoir pour les tpe
ça veut dire que toutes les entreprises
qui étaient au niveau de neuf salariés
vont passer avec cette qualification au
delà c'est à dire à des ca des
entreprises de 10 salariés avec toutes
les conséquences de seuil qui vont leur
tomber dessus
ils ont supprimé le crédit d'impôt
apprentissage et il met en oeuvre un
pacte de responsabilité qui en réalité
je les démontrer à d'ailleurs monsieur
moscovici ne pourra pas être utilisée
par les pme et les pmi pour une raison
simple c'est qu'ils ne peuvent pas
fournir la contreparties en termes
d'emploi
parce que pour une entreprise de neuf
salariés pourquoi je prends ça parce que
c'est l'immense majorité des entreprises
françaises neuf salariés et moins
eh bien c'est ce crédit d'impôt ce sera
dix mille euros de cadeaux qui leur est
fait sauf qu'en contrepartie on leur
demandera une dépense qui représente une
embauche c'est à dire vingt mille euros
donc c'est toujours la politique est
faite pour les gros pour ceux qui en
réalité n'ont pas besoin de l'aide de
l'état
c'est la même politique que celle qui a
été menée par nicolas sarkozy et on n'a
pas répondu à la question la grande
question comment va-t-on financer cela
augmentation de la csg
comment va-t-on le financer par une
nouvelle cure d'austérité mais j'imagine
qu'on aura ces informations après les
européennes à la volonté de réduire les
dépenses mais ça dépend quelle dépense
s'il s'agit de défendre et systèmes de
protection sociale
s'il s'agit de renier sur les
indemnisations des chômeurs c'est ce qui
a été fait on l'a vu en grèce en italie
au portugal avec les conséquences que
l'on connaît et qu'on ne nous dise pas
que ça va mieux puisque le troisième
plan grec est déjà en préparation dead
de sauvetage de l'euro sauf que là
encore madame merkel fait la même
politique que françois hollande elle dit
on en parlera après les européennes
parce qu'il faut bien que les français
ne connaissent pas la vérité pour
pouvoir envisager de voter encore pour
les socialistes pour l'ump je reviens
sur les très grandes entreprises
internationales marine le pen donc dans
lesquels on déroule le tapis rouge
on connaît votre opposition à la libre
circulation des personnes vous êtes
également contre la libre circulation
des capitaux pour être précis sur ce
point là un poids de près si je pense
qu'il faut avoir un contrôle on peut a
parfaitement envisager d'avoir un
contrôle ça serait d'ailleurs un bon
moyen objectivement de lutter contre la
fraude fiscale parce que les mêmes
notamment l'extrême gauche qui ne
cessent de râler contre la fraude
fiscale ils sont pour l'ouverture totale
des frontières alors faut savoir ce
qu'on veut
parce que si on n'ouvre totalement les
frontières alors on n'a pas défendu
qatar ou du koweit qui était représenté
à la lie à l'elysée lundi vous n'en
voulez pas je peux vous dire que les
fonds du qatar et de l'arabie saoudite
moi je serai à la tête de l'état jeu
ferai en sorte de ne pas livrer notre
économie à ces deux pays pour une raison
simple et une raisons éminemment
politique c'est que j'accuse ces pays
très clairement d'être les soutiens et
les financiers du terrorisme
international et du fondamentalisme
islamique partout voilà et continents et
payet qui était représenté à l'elysée
lundi présence et voilà ces pays
ces pays qui sont des esclavagistes
puisqu'on a appris que je crois il ya
400 450 indiens qui sont morts sur les
chantiers de la future coupe du monde je
crois au qatar mais tout ça on ferme les
yeux nous grand donneur de leçons de
morale à la terre entière grand
défenseur des droits de l'homme quand il
s'agit du kata en laye a plus personne
perd tout le monde ferme les yeux se
bouche les oreilles et ne voit pas ce
qu'est réellement ce pays pour des
raisons d'argent se fait acheter en
quelque sorte dont il achète notre
silence
et bien moi en l'occurrence je trouve ça
extrêmement dangereux est ce que vous
estimez qu'à moins de 20 % de bonnes
opinions aujourd'hui françois hollande
joue son va tout avec le pacte de
responsabilité que auquel vous croyez
pas apparemment non je n'y crois pas je
n'y crois pas il se sent mais il n'y a
pas un domaine de sa politique je crois
qu'il est susceptible demain d'entraîner
l'adhésion des français et les résultats
ne seront pas au rendez vous voilà
c'était une chose absolument clair il
n'y aura pas d' inversion de la courbe
du chômage et des signes encourageants
quand même hein on a une croissance un
peu plus soutenue que prévu à mes
couilles un rebond de consommation
regard des investissements aprilia 0 3%
de croissance 0,2 peut-être que ce soit
mais plutôt très honnêtement mais il ya
des signes positifs en plafonnant coq à
l'âne dette a atteint 2000 milliards ce
donc là encore personne ne parle
le chômage et atteindre des records 5
millions officiellement probablement
plus plus près de 7 millions 80 % des
cdd des emplois à des embauches l'année
dernière on était décédé devancé mais là
je vous parle de chiffres mais sans les
chômeurs en trois ans 77 % de baisse des
investissements étrangers l'année d'air
justement c'est contre ça qu'on essaie
d'augmenter l'attractivité des sites
industriels oui sauf qu'ils se trompent
le problème c'est qu'il ne fait pas le
bon constat donc temps qu'il fera pas le
bon constat il donnera pas les bons
médicaments donc le bon constat c'est
d'admettre que l'euro est beaucoup trop
cher que les pme/pmi attendent toujours
la promesse de françois hollande de
l'iace progressif et il ne l'a pas mise
en neige les sociétés par conséquent cet
impôt sur les sociétés les pme pmi la
paye plein pot quand les grandes
entreprises du cac 40 on le sait ne paye
elle que 8% et ses excès alors c'était
un certains évoquent un remaniement peut
être même avant les municipales et le
nom de claude bartolone revient à lui
qui avait critiqué l'europe de
l'austérité comme vous il ya un instant
est-ce que vous ne préféreriez jean marc
ayrault mais je crois que ça ne changera
strictement rien c'est je crois que les
français doivent prendre conscience que
la première chose à faire c'est de
libérer notre pays du carcan européen
construire cette prison qui a été
construite et par l'ump le ps et dans
lequel ils ont verrouillé le peuple
demande est d'accord de combats tribaux
cité son héros sont d'accord pour
essayer de déverrouiller à tout le monde
est d'accord ils sont d'accord parties
sont d'accord pour critiquer l'union
européenne pendant la campagne mais en
l'occurrence quand ils sont à strasbourg
ils continuent à voter toutes les
directives qui continuent à fermer un
triple tour la prison dans quelle ils
ont enfermé l'europe en parlant l'agent
perso je ne suis pas dupe des effets de
manche préélectoraux ce que je vois
c'est l'effet et les faits c'est qu'ils
veulent plus d'europe plus de 2
d'intégration comme ils disent
européenne françois hollande s'est rendu
ce mardi matin la grande mosquée de
paris est ce qu'ils se devaient selon
vous d'inaugurer ce mémorial du soldat
musulman
on connaît tous l'apport déterminant des
des soldats musulmans durant les gares
françaises
excusez moi je n'ai pas cette vision
communautariste moi c'est du coup je
trouve que cette manière de diviser les
français entre musulmans
chrétien juif ça me fait vomir voilà car
moi je crois à l'unité de la france et
ses soldats qui sont remarquables et qui
méritait cette mosquée qu'on leur a
offert d'accord mais ils étaient
français voilà et nous leur devons comme
à tous les soldats français
la reconnaissance du pays mais venir
faire du communautarisme et donc qu'on
ne se raconte pas d'histoires de
l'électoralisme
avec ces soldats morts je trouve ça
m'est vraiment critiquable plus haut
point voilà alors ils ont notre
reconnaissance comme on notre
reconnaissance tous les soldats français
qui sont morts pour défendre notre pays
mais arriver à les diviser jusque dans
la mort j'avoue que je trouve ça
terrifiant et ça répond d'ailleurs on le
sait très bien ça répond à quoi ça
répond exclusivement à une manipulation
politicienne
parce que monsieur hollande a reçu des
sondages sur son bureau qui lui disent
que les français musulmans qui ont voté
beaucoup pour lui
s'abstiendrait donc il est inquiet dont
qui lancent des signaux mai mais tout ça
c'est par exemple respect peut-être à
l'ump qui essaye justement de séduire
cet électorat qui a peut être troublé
par certaines réformes de société sur la
famille vous vous partout c'est pas
cette concurrence alors l'électorat
musulman pas digne moi je m'adresse à
tous les français je ne les détermine
pas en fonction de la couleur de leur
peau
je ne détermine pas en fonction de leur
religion ça c'est la politique de
l'apartheid et c'est cela oui de
l'apartheid oui de l'apartheid
ce qui consiste à séparer les hommages
les politiques en fonction de la couleur
de la peau de la religion ça s'appelle
l'apartheid alors alors c'est de
l'apartheid doux mais c'est de
l'apartheid quand même et le ps se rend
là coupable d'une grande violation des
règles et des valeurs de la république
dise la marine le pen alors que françois
hollande a décidé de lancer l'armée
française en centrafrique pour essayer
justement de réconcilier les communautés
religieuses et ethniques avec toutes les
exactions qu'on a connue la france va
envoyer des renforts supplémentaires est
ce que vous estimez que la démarche est
la bonne pas de face on ne peut pas
faire autrement cher monsieur
en clair à partir du moment où on a
décidé d'y
eh bien nous arrivons là bas ils nous
nous rendons compte qu'il faudrait le
rôle de la france a été positif on a
évité pour ce stade
à ce stade le génocide il faisait bien
dans ce petit millier de soldats
supplémentaires et je crois que l'union
européenne nous en a proposé 500 dans
l'union européenne ferait mieux
d'ailleurs comme je les dis allah au
parlement européen de nous aider
financièrement pour supporter cette
intervention plutôt que de nous envoyer
quelques soldats européens quand jamais
mis les pieds en afrique de toute la rue
de l'espérance qui n'y connaissent rien
volé regretter mais vous ne condamnez
pearn amassé deux mentions non ça n'est
pas ce que je dois je ne dis pas on est
bien seul je le regrette je dis que
plutôt qu'une union européenne nous
envoie 500 soldats qui n'ont jamais vu
de leur vie un pays africain et non
jamais a fortiori combattu sur ces
territoires qui sont difficiles qui nous
laisse le faire on connaît bien cela
mais qui nous aident financièrement pour
qu'on ne supporte pas l'intégralité de
la charge financière de cette
intervention alors évoqué maintenant les
municipales donc avec ce sondage sur
hénin beaumont qui vous donnent gagnante
combien de villes visées vous
précisément
même si l'on vous connaissez des
difficultés à monter votre bolide
partout on en parle avec guillaume
daudin de l' agence france-presse
d'abord le reportage de camilla campus
anneaux qui a justement suivi manuel
valls dans le pas-de-calais dans sa
tournée anti front national financé par
les contribuables sous les feux des
projecteurs à lens
manuel valls vient officiellement
installé une nouvelle zone de sécurité
prioritaire un déplacement qui prend
vite des airs de campagne électorale
c
lance un choix stratégique ici marine le
pen a décroché la deuxième place aux
présidentielles de 2012
avec plus de 26 % des voix je vais pas
des campagnes anti je fais des campagnes
pour la république pour les valeurs il
faut la sécurité de nos concitoyens
donc le résumé mon action à cela ça
aurait être à côté de la plaque
aucune ambiguïté pour le ministre de
l'intérieur dans son entourage on
murmure tout de même le mot de tournée
anti fn trois semaines après non
beaumont il rencontre les lensois
au programme visite des commerçants un
petit mot avant de repartir prendre une
pause café dans cette boulangerie son
opération communication ne passe pas
inaperçu tu es pas on a lancé raid et
main à des gens
potentiellement
de sombres de son bord que ça va faire
changer d'avis ceux qui n'y sont pas
quoi
absent des élections municipales de 2008
le front national semble devenir un
concurrent de taille
le candidat fn de lens se sent même pris
pour cible par le ministre de
l'intérieur
c'est clairement un déplacement anti fn
à un mois quelques des élections c'est
une évidence
on peut se poser la question de savoir
si on peut on va pas saisir la
commission nationale des comptes de
campagne comme l'a fait monsieur briois
un abo
le candidat bleu marine reçoit jean
marie le pen le 1er mars
visiblement ps et fn n'hésite pas à
envoyer leur artillerie lourde pour la
conquête de l'hôtel de ville de lens
voilà guillaume donna est avec nous de
notre confrère de l'agencé presse qu'on
salue puisque c'est votre première
participation à preuve parfois guillaume
votre vos questions à marine le pen
bonsoir marine le pen vous avez dénoncé
à plusieurs reprises une tournée anti fn
de manuel valls est à dire steve brio à
votre candidat hénin beaumont a même
annoncé qu'il allait saisir la
commission nationale des comptes de
campagne est ce que vous pensez qu'il
peut faire baisser le score du fn aux
élections municipales
non je recule les faits remontent à la
fin c'est le dernier sondage démontre
sur hénin beaumont dans laissez passer
le front national est donné gagnant
voilà c'est que je colle invités à venir
vous voir partout qu'on peut gagner il
suffit de suivre manuel valls à la trace
il ya qu'un malheur c'est que c'est pas
son job quoi il est payé pour ça
ah il touche je crois un salaire de la
république ce ministre là il se déplace
avec beaucoup de personnels de sécurité
tout ça est payé par les contribuables
est ce que les contribuables sont
obligés de payer les tournées anti front
national de monsieur valls il le fait
parce que ça hein il est là bas aussi
pour pouvoir apprécier ce soit sur le
plan sécuritaire le précise voyons à un
moment ah bon il ya une âme au mans est
allé voir quoi monsieur alors à dans ces
cas là ça va écouter il est allé visiter
rien du tout les forces de sécurité
pas une un moment mais à côté à hénin
beaumont il est allé aux voeux du maire
qui avait des yeux comme ça et et qu'il
n'avait d'ailleurs pas invité
donc il s'est invité à beaumont donc je
dis que quand on a les résultats aussi
pitoyable que ceux de manuel valls en
matière de lutte contre l'insécurité en
matière d'augmentation de la présence
clandestine dans notre pays
eh bien on se fait son job et on n'est
pas agent électoral des pauvres
candidats ps de 6 ou de la cité
municipale les sandra les sondages sont
un peu contrasté donc il ya un moment où
les on vous annonce gagnant il ya des
bonnes villes par exemple 37% à
brignoles 35% à béziers qui a des villes
comme paris ou vos listes ne ferait que
8 % à bordeaux c'est 6% strasbourg 7 %
est-ce que vous avez l'impression qu'il
ya un petit tassement dans les sondages
ces derniers temps non mais je vous
aimeriez bien j'ai je lis vos tweets
régulièrement et je vois que ça vous
ferait plaisir maintenant je ne le crois
pas voilà par conséquent je pense que
tout va bien et que dans les villes que
vous citez notamment paris on était à 3
donc si on passe la barre des 10 comme
je le crois ce sera une multiplication
assez spectaculaire du score tout de
même je connais pas beaucoup de partis
politiques qui d'une élection à l'autre
et capables soit capable d'apporter une
si forte augmentation de ces scores
alors bien sûr il ya des villes plus ou
moins bonne pour le franc la salle pour
une raison simple c'est qu'il ya des
villes qui ont une ancienneté
d'implantation locale plus ou moins
importante la progression du fn dans les
sondages et même électoralement personne
ne la conteste par contre par exemple en
novembre le fn était annoncé à 22%
d'intentions de vote loin du nid cipal
ce mois ci c'est 15%
c'est inquiétant quand même monsieur
gaudin parce que vous êtes censé être un
spécialiste de la politique vous savez
bien pourquoi il ya une telle différence
ah mais il faut lui répondre faut
réduire et prévoyez les questions je
vais lui répondre je n'ai pas posé de
question j'ai dit c'est inquiétant froid
se recycler une affiche
mais parce que mois de novembre vous
interroger les gens vous interrogez 100%
des villes sauf que au mois de novembre
les électeurs français ne savent pas
dans quelle ville y aura un candidat
front national
à partir du moment où vous arrivez au
mois de janvier eh bien les ans les gens
savent demande notamment s'il souhaite
voter pour le bien sûr monsieur dowd
homme et vous faut pas prendre les
français pour des idiots vous savez si
les français savent que dans leur vie il
n'y a pas de candidat front national ils
n'ont pas vous dire je vais voter front
national au municipal jusqu'à pas de
candidat front national dans leur ville
donc en réalité c'est ça qui explique
cette baisse nous sommes présents nous
serons présents dans à peu près la
moitié des villes de plus de 10 mille
habitants dans l'autre moitié c'est
comme si on faisait zéro en quelque
sorte donc nos électeurs qui n'ont pas
le choix de voter pour un candidat front
national bien soit ils s'abstiennent
soit ils reportent leur vote sur un
autre candidat ce qui est tout à fait
normal au fn plusieurs personnes parlent
de cinq à dix villes gagnable aux
municipales est ce que ça vous paraît
une fourchette des mois je donne pas
fourchette je ne donne pas de fourchette
nous verrons bien
mais moi je pense que nous sommes
capables de gagner des villes lesquels
c'est absolument impossible de le savoir
personne ne le sait d'ailleurs car avec
la règle de la triangulaire et des
quadrangulaires il est impossible de
faire une projection
donc il y a et je derme merci de me
permettre de de préciser ce qui est
apparu dans certains médias faussement
il y à une quinzaine de villes dans
lequel nous avons le potentiel pour
gagner voilà nous sommes à un niveau
électoral qui nous permet d'être dans la
marge où l'on peut gagner une ville
j'espère que dans ceux séquence ville
potentiellement gagnable nous en
gagnerons le plus possible parce que
vous espérez dans combien de villes
passé des accords locaux avec l'ump par
exemple non je ne l'espère pas ça n'est
pas notre politique
vous avez fait une proposition non c'est
le protocole qui est sur la table pour
l'économie c'est je pense que c'est vrai
il y aura peut-être quelques cas entre
les deux tours elle nous les analyserons
si on nous en fait la demande si
effectivement des candidats signent la
charte du rassemblement bleu marine car
nous ne faisons pas d'accord politiciens
ne faisant des accords si nécessaire
politique bas c'est normal
elles n'ont pas faire des accords avec
des gens qui ne sont en désaccord avec
les dix points qui nous apparaissent
incontournables de notre agent dit s'y
rallierait à vous en faites assez ça
exactement mais mais bon voilà pour
l'instant donc y aura peut-être quelques
cas mais la règle générale c'est que
nous serons présents au second tour pour
gagner des villes bien sûr mais aussi
pour avoir le plus de consignes mais
vous avez quand même donner un chiffre
vous estimez que vous avez une quinzaine
de villes quand tu es niable l'habitant
une potentiel électoral nous permettent
d'être à un niveau où sa ville sont
gagnables dire dans vous avez dit à
perpignan lors de votre meeting ce
samedi vous ne demanderait aucun maire
élus d'aller au delà de ces compétences
municipales
pourtant plusieurs de vos candidats
soutiennent des mesures de préférence
locale par un clou et aliot à perpignan
il a parlé de réserver les marchés
publics aux entreprises du département
qui souffre de concurrence déloyale
il a aussi parlé de choisir des
entreprises qui embauchent de la main
d'oeuvre locale
est ce qu'un maire peut prés mettre en
place ce genre de disposition
eh oui monsieur dowd a tout à fait non
c'est parfaitement légal et
vous venez dans nord pas de calais ou
conseil régional vous apercevrez que le
groupe front national a déposé cinq ou
six motions et veut visant justement à
modifier les critères d'attribution car
vous le savez dans un marché public
il y à des critères et on accorde un
pourcentage à chaque critère or dans ces
critères il y en a deux qui nous
apparaissent très intéressant et qui
peuvent permettre de donner un privilège
aux entreprises locales c'est le critère
le critère écologique est notamment
considéré que l'empreinte carbone d'une
entreprise qui arrive avec des camions
d'europe de l'est
eh bien ça fait baisser en quelque sorte
son attractivité dans le choix du marché
public et donc qu'une entreprise est
proche et moins plus ce critère est
positif pour lui et puis aussi critère
social s'est autorisé par l'union
européenne
c'est tout petit et un certain qu'on lui
fasse tout ça c'est pour détourner quand
même les situe la stupidité des
interdictions qui sont imposées par
l'union européenne les entreprises qui
embauchent de la main d'oeuvre locale
c'est possible et alors nous aussi
et alors donc je vous dise dans ce
critère social vous apercevrez qu'il y à
deux éléments très intéressants
le la non suppression d'emplois et les
embauches éventuelles et donc ces deux
critères l'année ensemble permettent de
donner un petit avantage à nos
entreprises nationales et en
l'occurrence aux entreprises locales par
rapport aux entreprises étrangères
parler de réserver les marchés publics
aux entreprises du département
réserver ses origines ça veut dire que
des entreprises en démarrage
mais je crois qu'avec ces deux critères
avec avec la mise en oeuvre de ces deux
critères dans une immense majorité de
cas on peut permettre aux entreprises
qui sont de la région de pouvoir être
mieux placé que des entreprises qui
seraient des entreprises étrangères donc
c'est tout à fait légal et vous avez un
candidat à périgueux qui sur son site
internet propose la plus regardée
regardez programme jeux voici propose
l'application de la préférence nationale
pour l'attribution des logements sociaux
est-ce que c'est faisable aussi non ça
ça n'est pas faisable lui dire alors
ouais il faudra lui dire mais
heureusement que monsieur dowd à la
cellule riposte au front national 6 à
l'ump ou au ps mais avec beaucoup
d'attention
il le démontre ce soir avec nous bio
filtre polémique lancée par
jean-françois copé soir il ya beaucoup
de choses à faire en matière de logement
puisque vous savez vous vous intéressez
au programme municipal
il ya notamment exigé quand on est maire
que l'on respecte la la manière dont une
honte on utilise les locaux car bien
souvent les logements sociaux sont
accordées à des gens qui n'ont aucun
respect pour ce logement qu'ils
n'utilisent pas en respectant le cahier
des charges
donc là le maire peut exiger que le
cahier des charges de l'eau d'une
occupation paisible et sereine soit
restauré aux gens je pense à bord je
pense à des gens qui ne respectent pas
du bruit après 22h dunant qui sont
beaucoup plus nombreux que le nombre qui
pour lequel le logement est accordé que
six coups sûrs des choses qui arrivent
oh oui ça arrive ça arrive je vous le
confirme bon et puis et puis je pense
également que il y aura très
probablement moyens et j'engagerai le
débat juridique sur ce point de respect
réserver une partie des logements
sociaux aux personnes âgées car je crois
que les personnes âgées sont en très
grandes difficultés financières qu'elle
ne et qu'elles ne font pas l'objet d'un
traitement a pas elle devrait faire
l'objet sur le terrain j'ai traitement à
part les jardins au candidat propose de
réserver les logements sociaux ou les
aides de leur municipalité aux habitants
de leur ville est ce que c'est un petit
peu normal non mais par rapport aux et
vous voulez que par rapport aux
étrangers en disant ça sera ça sera que
nos habitants et pas les étrangers est
ce que c'est possible
non ça n'est pas possible ça en état de
la loi ce n'est pas possible nous mener
ce que nous nous battons même de faire
campagne sur eux
avec ces propositions alors c'est dedans
c'est vrai c'est vrai que moi je vais
vous dire partout où je vais je vois des
candidats socialistes qui font campagne
en vendant une gare tgv qui évidemment
ne verra jamais lieu je vois beaucoup de
choses j'entends beaucoup de choses dans
une dans des campagnes municipales santé
mais je propose mais bien sûr non c'est
pas un mensonge
je crois que ils ont le désir d'accorder
un privilège aux habitants de leur ville
c'est vous qui dites que c'est par
rapport aux étrangers
est ce que ces marchés où j'habite en de
leurs villes plus sûres
il me semble que c'est l'un de vos
secrétaire départemental usa doivent
être aidés avant les étrangers le prince
charmant mais après ce monsieur de d'un
sas est une c'est une déclaration de
politique générale que auquel j'adhère
bien sûr une part est normal que les
habitants de la ville soit quand même
et quand même une priorité par rapport
aux étrangers je vous donne un exemple
les clés rendent par exemple parlons-en
lorsque des roms s'installent installe
un camp illégal dans une ville et que le
préfet arrive en exigeant que la
municipalité logent les roms clandestins
avant les habitants de la ville vous
trouvez ça normal
et bien moi je trouve ça profondément
scandaleux et donc je suis parfaitement
d'accord pour envisager les moyens de
pouvoir pourquoi pas d'ailleurs
réfléchir juridiquement a une ancienneté
dans la ville pourquoi est ce que ceux
qui sont installés nationaux ça ne se
fait pas au niveau local en mer mais en
amont monsieur monsieur sur le logement
quand même bon pourquoi ne pas envisager
la possibilité juridique par exemple de
tenir compte de l'ancienneté de
l'ancienneté d'installation dans la
ville pour pouvoir
comment accorder les logements sociaux
tout ça ça se discute on peut très bien
envisager cette possibilité alors qu'il
restait une minute pour
vous avez un d'alors le jean françois
copé a relancé une polémique sur les sur
les livres qu'ils s'attaquaient aux
stéréotypes sexuels et il ya certains de
vos candidats qui demande le retrait de
ses livres par exemple votre candidat à
toulon demande dans la bibliothèque de
tout le monde le retrait d'un certain
nombre de livres
quelle est votre position sur le sujet
je suis contre le retrait de tout livre
de toute bibliothèque
je suis pour l'introduction d'un certain
nombre de livres plutôt que leurs treize
emplois qu'elles n'importent tous ceux
qui n'y sont pas ceux de demain voilà
par exemple ceux notamment qui n'ont
peut-être pas l'heur de plaire mais
s'est vu que vous aviez une grande
conversation là dessus monsieur de
monsieur zemmour par exemple même s'ils
devraient ou non vous êtes un très bon
enquêteur messieurs le mandat de la cie
vous ayez aller dans les bibliothèques
de france pour vérifier
j'en suis quand même pas si on l'a
forcément c'était dégoûtant voilà donc
des gens comme d'acti expose une pensée
qui ne plaît pas au pouvoir voilà je
pense que il faut qu'ils aient tous les
livres car moi je crois à l'intelligence
des français
je crois que les français doivent
pouvoir avoir tous les livres entre les
mains et se faire eux mêmes une opinion
ça n'est pas aux municipalités de
choisir quel livre on lit ou pas quant à
ces livres là qui sont destinés à des
enfants de 4 ans je crois bon il me
semble que les parents sont là pour
mettre entre les mains de leurs enfants
les livres que les parents considèrent
comme don pour leurs enfants mais ont
quand même assez rare de voir un petit
gamin de 4 ans je vais aller tout seul
pour aller choisir ses livres dans la
bibliothèque
merci guillaume pour votre sens de la
rigueur merci d'avoir est avec nous
avons une honte pour vous mener une
enquête sur lui c'est pas possible
on aimerait quand même bien avoir la
liste des livres que vous avez envie de
faire entrer dans les bibliothèques
mejia faudra nous la donnait marine le
pen
des livres des ligues de renaud camus de
zemmour il ya des sorties vous
accompagne beaucoup d'ailleurs alors
dites moi vous envoyer un mot sur manuel
valls la ville avait critiqué tout à
l'heure on l'a vu voulu vous voyez un
destin national destin non pas
particulièrement
non je crois que monsieur valse
bénéficie en réalité d'un effet miroir
d'une là bénéficié d'ailleurs s'est
terminée d'une popularité en effet
miroir avec madame taubira
voilà mais je pense qu'il a beaucoup
d'ambition oui commission héros et de
monsieur hollande am stram gram pic et
pic et colégram permis gratte il s'est
en outre si vous avez 10 ans perrine
tarneaud arrive juste avant ce détour
par l'oise où vous êtes présente
d'ailleurs ce mardi soir et où aurélia
mousli a rencontré des électeurs qui
sont prêts apparemment à se détourner
des partis traditionnels de droite comme
de gauche
une démarche d'ailleurs qui semble
autant politique que sociologique dans
certaines communes le front national a
bien du mal à boucler ses listes
mais ici à formerie commune de 2000
habitants dans l'oise
le maire sortant aura bien face à lui
une liste rassemblement bleu marine une
politisation que l'élu sans étiquette de
la bourgade ne comprends pas je pense
que la liste qui est en face de moi donc
beaucoup d'expérience puisqu'il n'ya
aucun ancien élu ou très peu qui ont
obtenu deux subirait des villes
importantes ou moyenne et donc il ne
faut pas de connaissance suffisante de
la commune on rentre dans la politique
politicienne dont quelques années c'est
évident dans le canton voisin à
grandvilliers la candidate frontiste a
totalisé 54 % des suffrages à la
législative partielle de l'année
dernière ici pas de liste fn aux
municipales pourtant la population
locale voit dans le front national à
remed à tous les maux moi je pense que
là les essences avoir contesté fait
parti socialiste
avant de prendre une telle que les gens
en ont marre des gens en ont peut-être
marre de la droite marque de gauche sont
tellement été déçus tellement été
arrangés qui veulent changer les hommes
politiques nous abandonne alors que au
front national reste ce sont des gens
qui sont nés dans la dans le coin qui
vivent avec nous qui travaillent avec
nous ce sont ces gens là qui sont l'
exaspération sentiment d'abandon des
thématiques que stéphane rozès connaît
bien
pour le politologue l' isolement des
populations et l'arrivée de nouveaux
habitants venus de la ville favorise le
vote frontiste dans des zones
d'isolement géographique social
territorial le vote front national
apparaît comme un substitut cognitique
cette année dans l'oise une dizaine de
liste rassemblement bleu marine devrait
se lancer dans la bataille des
municipales en 2001 dans ce même
département
le fn avait pu boucler que de liste par
la perrine tarneaud vite avec nous au
pèlerinage en question à marine le pen
on va parler des municipales jusqu'aux
européennes les européennes vous avez
trois élus actuellement bruno gollnisch
votre père et vous même vous viser une
fourchette entre 15 à 20 euros députés
en 2014
et est-ce que visé est ce que vous visez
pour vous le rôle de leader d'un futur
groupe parlementaire souverainistes à
rosso sont pas des choses qui se décide
à l'avance en règle générale d'abord on
construit un groupe c'est déjà le plus
important est la question
dans la construction la question de la
présidence d'un groupe arrive après que
ce groupe était construit moi je pense
que nous aurons un groupe et c'est ça je
crois les amitiés avec des gens avec
lesquels nous sommes en contact régulier
nous nous apprécions nous travaillons
ensemble depuis de nombreuses années
pour certains le fp autrichien qui est
très bien positionné pour les élections
européennes
je l'espère le pvv de geert wilders qui
donnait en tête aux pays bas les
démocrates suédois avec lesquels nous
travaillons depuis longtemps y en a qui
ne veulent pas de vous comme les anglais
do you keep oui enfin les anglais sont
en grève ça n est pas et ils veulent
garder ça surtout il pourrait vous
empêcher de faire le vôtre alors ils
pouvaient pendant que géographe
extrémistes maintenant parce que non
parce que les contextes nous avons sont
des contacts qui ne viennent pas du
groupe do you keep mais c'est vrai que
l'équipe aimerait conserver la
présidence de son groupe et avoir son
groupe à lui mais on ne sait jamais faut
pas insulter l'avenir s'il n'y arrive
pas rien ne dit que des rapprochements
ne passait plus court un peu trop
extrême
oui c'est le meilleur moyen de se dédire
vol easy rider c'est le meilleur moyen
se dédiaboliser soi même vu qu'ils sont
victimes comme nous d'ailleurs d'attac
qui sont extrêmement brutales comme à
chaque fois que vous allez à l'encontre
du système
à chaque fois les méthodes sont les mais
vous savez j'ai pas confiance 1 pour
être tout à fait honnête
à chaque fois on vous traite de fasciste
de raciste d'ailleurs ça manque beaucoup
d'imagination
photo ap tout essayé de renouveler un
petit peu et que l'usiné italienne
ils s'aiment radicalisés depuis sa
sortie du gouvernement italien en mai le
la ligue du nord c'est beaucoup a
indiqué il ya un malheur c'est qu'ils
ont changé justement le président l'a
dernièrement mois de décembre donc je
pense que justement la ligue du nord
d'abord à changer politiquement il
devenu très eurosceptique alors qu'ils
étaient plutôt européiste et que sur
toute une série de sujets ils sont en
train d'évoluer
est-ce qu'ils vont évoluer jusqu'à
pouvoir intégrer un groupe comme le
nôtre peut-être nous verrons bien
est ce que vous vous ces dernières
années et fait évoluer le front national
oui ou non marine le pen bâti le moment
je le fait grossir par définition quand
on m'a aussi plu synology idéologique à
ba2 le problème du front national c'est
que c'est un vrai parti mais pour
répondre à ma question est ce que vous
nous coupez non voilà donc je vais vous
répondre je fais juste une pause d'une
sérieuse pour respirer voilà donc ne
profitez pas pour reprendre la parole
c'est un vrai parti donc c'est un parti
qui s'attache à répondre aux
préoccupations des français ni aux
préoccupations il dit
nos préoccupations nées à 20 ans est-ce
qu'ils évoluent mais bien sûr ils
évoluent parce que les menaces qui
pèsent sur la france évolue est ce que
le terme c'est de changer le nom du
front national pour vous non mais non
non non non non non pour l'instant ça
explique pour la non ce n'est pas ce que
j'ai dit j'ai dit que pour l'instant ça
n'était pas d'actualité mais j'ai eu du
mal à terminer ma phrase c'est peut-être
pour ça donc il était le danger il ya
trente ans c'était le socialo communisme
aujourd'hui le danger c'est l'excès de
libéralisme
par conséquent encore une fois nous
apportons des réponses à des problèmes
qui existent pas des problèmes qui
existent pas est ce que comme le ps ou
l'ump est ce que vous effectuerez tout
votre mandat de député européen s'il est
élu et bien sûr en mai prochain
el ghazi rejetée par ate mandat bah je
ne sais pas si ça se trouve je serai
élue présidente de la république en 2010
est serait obligée d'interrompre son
mandat de député européen
vous ne rêvez pas pour toute la
législature européenne a beau si les
français décident de me porter à
l'elysée la présidentielle et je pense
je pense qu nettement les électeurs le
comprendront sur le référendum suisse
sur l'immigré sur l'immigration que vous
avez soutenu un don vous avez approuvé
le résultat est ce que de cette façon là
vous ne tirez pas aussi une balle dans
le pied des cent cinquante mille
travailleurs français transfrontalier
qui vont travailler donc chaque jour en
suisse et qui sont menacés par ce
référendum
je crois pas du tout je pense je pense
que l'immense majorité ne sont pas du
tout menacée par ce référendum das
d'abord ça c'est la première chose
et deuxièmement je pense que c'est la
responsabilité de la france de créer de
l'emploi en france est de délivrer des
salaires qui sont dignes que c'est la
raison pour laquelle il ya énormément
ils sont 56 à la maman c'est qui qui
partant en suisse maintenant que les
suisses ne veulent pas qu au travers
d'une immigration très importante il y
ait une pression à la baisse sur leurs
salaires je le comprend d'autant mieux
que je dis la même chose en france à
l'égard d'autres
étrangers qui viennent travailler en
france et qui réclament des salaires qui
sont effectivement des salaires très bas
et qui du coup contribuer à peser à la
baisse sur les salaires donc voyez j'ai
une cohérence dans mon projet je défends
le droit des peuples à se défendre
lorsqu'ils sont français mais aussi
lorsqu'ils sont suisses mais sauf qu'ils
vont venir sans doute grossir les rangs
des chômeurs français mais ça c'est la
russie n'ont plus de boulot on ait un
sens oui mais d'accord mais enfin
écoutez considérer qu'il faut que les
français aillent travailler ailleurs
pour pouvoir avoir un boulot excusez moi
mais moi je fais de la politique donc là
pour apporter des solutions pour que mon
pays et de l'emploi pas pour déverser
des salariés dans des pays étrangers
pour qu'ils aillent chercher le travail
que les politiques n'arrivent pas à
fabriquer en france serait bienvenu en
france il obtiendrait quel pourcentage
quel pourcentage de oui selon vous je
pense entre 60 et 65 % ce qui est très
intéressant dans ce référendum c'est que
les suisses ont aussi voté pour la
priorité nationale
la priorité nationale qui je m'exprime
je m'explique parce que souvent elle est
qu'à tuer caricaturer cette priorité
nationale qui consiste à dire que à
compétence égale un français doit
pouvoir avoir une priorité d'accès à
l'emploi par rapport à un étranger non
pas par rapport à un immigré car le
concept immigrés ne veut rien dire dans
les immigrés il ya des français
d'origine immigrée
vous avez peut-être vu aussi le cri
d'alarmé des pme suisses aujourd'hui
qu'ils disent attention c'est le retour
de la paperasserie la bureaucratie va
falloir qu'on remplissent des
formulaires et des formulaires hébreu
porte qu'on privilégie d'abord les
salariés suisses et pas les étrangers
ici vous avez des grosses entreprises
qui songe à se délocaliser en irlande de
quitter la suisse pour aller en europe
de l'est
est ce que veut dire quoi faire à
grammont n'y a pas qu'en france alors
que dans l'entreprise ont des intérêts
divergent de ceux des peuples non mais
le gel des investissements en suisse
ld du goût du coup c'est décidé c'est le
tissu des pme qui sous tendent à moi je
veux bien tout ce que vous voulez mais
nous on a fait la libre circulation
totale en france il ya 77 % de baisse
des investissements étrangers donc ce
n'est pas une question de frontières
c'est juste une question de santé
économique d'un pays et d'attractivité
d'un pays
je pense que la suisse est attractive et
que personne ne partira de suisse vous
le dis très clairement de la même
manière je ne crois pas une demi-seconde
que l'union européenne va imposer comme
elle l'a menacé de le faire des
sanctions à l'égard de la sambre voici
trois heures
heureusement je m'interroge si si ça je
peux vous sur ce mois ci monsieur car en
suisse à la différence de la france on
respecte la volonté du peuple on
considère que le peuple est souverain et
quand il dit quelque chose personne la
classe politique suisse envisage de ne
pas respecter ce qu'a dit le peuple
suisse
à la différence de la france où on a
violé le référendum le résultat du
référendum de 2005 est notre question
qu'on peut se poser c'est pourquoi
est-ce qu'on menace la suisse de
contrepartie de sanctions en matière
mais et avec le maroc et avec le canada
à l'accord de libre échange que l'union
européenne a signé la contrepartie ça a
été l'ouverture totale des frontières la
libre circulation je ne crois pas de mac
est sûre parce qu'entre robert n'a pas
plutôt intérêt à se souder
c'est plutôt casse ou combattre sadok
strictement rien dire est ce qu'ils sont
de rien dire ah bon est ce que la
souveraineté à ce moment là elle n'a pas
un sens plutôt au niveau européen qu'au
niveau national
non d'ailleurs la preuve en est c'est
que ça ne marche pas la preuve en est
c'est que grenier cornec wii nommé
d'accord l'union soviétique aussi on a
cherché à leur corps et je mets un plus
pour les pays de l'union européenne de
voir cette foule un des niveaux
nationaux madame réponse même si
j'envoie mon sens la mondiale il a dit
non si on vous dit on est en train de se
diluer dans la mondialisation on est en
train d'opérer le saccage économique et
sociale à cause des règles mondialiste
qui nous sont imposées par l'union
européenne est ce que vous savez qu'il
ya eu l'année dernière 30 %
d'augmentation des travailleurs détachés
en france est ce que vous savez qu'il ya
des grands chantiers français où 40% de
ceux qui travaillent sont des étrangers
qui vont travailler dans les pays
frontaliers
c'est vrai il ya beaucoup de nos jeunes
qui fuient la france et si vous
considérez qu'il faut s'en réjouir
et bien moi je ne m'en réjouis pas loin
de là je préférerais que les jeunes
français aient envie de rester en france
parce qu'ils espèrent y trouver un
emploi ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui une petite question
d'actualité nationale pour finir entre
sarkozy et patrick buisson et
visiblement c'est fini ça vous inspire
quoi
plus rien ce matin sur europe 1 à propos
d'europe
que pensez vous de la jeunesse d'ukraine
qui se mobilisent pour justement à
adhérer aux valeurs européennes pour
comme c'est bien présent pas bah oui
oui c'est sans nuance attendait comment
voulez-vous je dire deux choses je vais
vous dire il ya l'envié et la jeunesse
ce tour du côté de ses valeurs alors moi
je vais vous dire la vérité c'est que la
manière dont vous présentez ça est
extrêmement binaire 5 août et bisounours
ça il ya des gros méchants d'un côté
puis les très très gentil de l'eau fait
réagir le problème c'est que dans les
opposants et c'est un vrai problème dans
les opposants russes au gouvernement
russe
il y à une partie craignent un pardon il
ya une partie qui sont des mouvements
qu'on qualifierait où la très largement
en france de nous donner on agit c'est
vrai voilà d'accord même est donc juste
présenter les choses telles qu'elles
sont plutôt que de donner une vision
encore une fois la guimauve de ce qui se
passe en temps si une part de leur
dignité vous les avez bien sûr mais
l'ukraine est un pays l'ukraine tapis
historiques liant est tiraillé entre son
côté européen et son côté russe c'est un
vrai souci et j'espère qu'ils arriveront
à trouver par l'intermédiaire des
élections une issue démocratique à ces
problèmes car ce serait dramatique de
voir l'ukraine arraché en deux est allé
jusqu'à la partition alors une petite
question sur les européennes
on n'a pas parlé de jean marie le pen
candidat à 85 ans est ce que le monde le
mandat de trois ans à partir de quel âge
pour vous il n'y a pas de mandat du trot
il n'y a pas de mandat de trop c'est aux
électeurs de décider je crois merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous la
semaine prochaine nous serons au salon
d'agriculture au public sénat d'ailleurs
va déployer pas mal d'émissions à partir
de samedi a très vite